the secret to gaining the upper hand and
negotiations is giving the other side
the illusion of control and the illusion
of control is typically best given with
either questions that begin with the
words what or how well what and how
should be the form of nearly any
question where you're trying to gather
information and it's actually one of the
ways we say no the first and best way to
say no to anyone is how am I supposed to
do that now the other side actually has
no idea as to the number of things
you've done with them at the same time
you've conveyed to them you have a
problem it's something that we also
refer to as forced empathy because one
of the reasons why we exercise tactical
empathy is because we want the other
side to see us fairly we want them to
see our position we want them to see the
issues we have we want to see the
constraints that we have and when you
say to somebody how am I supposed to do
that you make them take a look at your
situation before they respond and they
think about it in a number of different
ways at a number of different people
I've coached with negotiations who have
felt completely helpless they felt
completely taken hostage one instance
where a woman thought she was taken
hostage of the future and she just
wasn't getting paid they called her up
to give him more work and we taught her
to say trained or counseled her to say
how am I supposed to do that they
thought about it for a while I said
you're right you can't
I noticed that response is not word for
word directly responsive to her question
what they responded to was they felt
like she said to them I can't do this
anymore I've reached my limit and it's a
way to establish a limit in a way that
doesn't back the other side into a
corner you really want to be able to let
out know
a little bit at a time and the first way
to start letting out know as an answer
is how am I supposed to do that now
ultimately with that question we all
imagine that the other side is going to
say because I said so
because you have to that's actually
where you ultimately want to be with
that question because when you say how
am I supposed to do that and the other
side says because if you want this deal
you'll have to what you just found out
is they've been pushed to the limit on
that issue as far as they'll go
and that paternal question is have I
gotten everything I could on that was on
the table that's a great way to find out
whether or not you've gotten everything
you could on that particular term
because the other side most angry
response is because you have to which is
not them walking away it's not them
terminating the deal it's not them
giving you any more of an ultimatum it's
them saying no I've got no more room to
give without the negotiations breaking
off so given the other side the illusion
of control while signaling limits it's a
great way to stay in the conversation
and find out that you're not leaving
anything on the table I was coaching a
real estate negotiation recently and
that the agent was trying to lease a
very expensive home in the Hollywood
Hills and the first time they said to
the leasing agent how we supposed to do
that a leasing agent relented on a
number of the terms conversation
continued for a while they came to
another term that was pretty much almost
an impasse and the person doing the
negotiation says how we supposed to do
that
and the leasing agent said if you want
the house you're going to have to do it
which was a confirmation that they've
gotten as much as it could have out of
that term so it's a great way to give
the other side the illusion of control
because what many people need to feel
like they're in control in a negotiation
and when they feel like they're out of
control they're impossible to deal with
so the more you let the other side
like they're in control the more
amenable they are to collaboration you
really don't want people to feel out of
control